Did you sleep?
No, I'll sleep at the hotel.
Welcome to Berlin.
Can you tell me what you remember?
I was in a taxi.
I crashed.
I don't know how I got here.
You have been in a coma for four days.
We couldn't find any identification with you.
What's your name?
I'm Dr. Martin Harris.
I've been gone for four days. My wife is out there in a city she doesn't know.
Excuse me sir. Do you have an invitation?
That's my wife over there.
Liz.
Do I know you?
What's wrong? It's me,...
...your husband.
Martin.
You are Dr. Martin Harris?
Last time I looked.
Is this some kind of a joke?
You know this man?
No.
Liz.
Get him out of here.
Liz, Liz.
There are no rules with severe trauma of this kind.
Memories get lost or fractured.
I'm not crazy. Somewhere there's proof I'm me.
I was in your taxi. We crashed.
How did you find me?
I need to know what happened.
It's not safe for you. There are people watching.
They had me convinced I was crazy, but when they came to take me, I knew.
It's a simple code.
These mean anything to you?
It's my wife's writing.
They have passports, credit cards, family photos.
You really don't remember anything.
Get your hands off me.
Who are these people? They can become anyone.
The question is why would they want to take your place.
I don't know who this man is, but you have to arrest him or many people will die.
There is no Martin Harris.
He doesn't exist.
I am Martin Harris.
I didn't forget everything.